i'm going to do one more video on
entropy maybe i'll do more in the future
but i thought i would at least right now
do one more because i really want to
make clear the idea of entropy is a
macro state variable so let me write
that down and s which is entropy
is a macro state variable i'm going to
write macro
in bold red it's a macro
state variable
and i want to emphasize this and i
talked a little bit about it in my
previous video but i think even then i
wasn't as exact as i needed to be and
the reason why i want to say it's macros
because there's a very strong temptation
to point to particular micro states and
say does this have higher entropy or
lower entropy than another for example
the the classic one even i did this
you know you have a actually let me make
a bigger thicker lines okay
so you have
say you have this
box
that has a divider in it
and we've gone through this multiple
times
let me
draw the divider like right there
okay
so we say at first if we have a system
where all of the molecules
are
over here
so that's our first scenario and then
our second scenario we studied this a
lot we blow up the wall here
we blow up the wall here and we actually
calculated the entropy
control okay let me copy it and then i'm
going to paste it
so let me put these next to each other
all right so i have these two things and
then the second time i blew away this
wall let me blow it away
okay let me erase the wall there and
then we said once the system reaches
equilibrium again remember for a system
of these macro state variables like
pressure like volume like temperature
like entropy are only defined once the
system is in equilibrium
so once the system is in equilibrium
again you know these particles are now
allowing the same number of particles so
maybe some
let me erase some of these particles let
me move them let me see if i can select
some
so
whoops let me see
i could select
these particles
and i could move them
there so we'll have a more even that's
not a good way to do it let me just
redraw i said one two three four five
six seven eight particles
let me erase what i have
i'll make it with a more even
distribution
so then
once i blow away the wall i might have
one two three four five six seven eight
now the reason why i'm doing all of this
is because there's a temptation to say
that this state
this state what i just drew you when i
you know made sure to blow these away
and draw eight more i drew a micro state
this is a micro state
this is a microstate where actually
anytime someone's actually drawing
molecules for you they're drawing a
microstate
they're drawing a microstate
now i want to be very clear this
microstate does not have more entropy
than this microstate in fact microstates
you don't have entropy you can't even
entropy does not make sense what you can
say
is a system
what you can say and i'm at this time
i'll draw without the particles that if
i have a container that is this big
that contains so it has some volume
so volume is equal to v1 its temperature
is equal to t1 and it has
eight particles in it this has some
entropy associated with it and what we
can say is if we were to double the size
of this container
if we were to double the size of this
container which we did by blowing away
that wall
now all of a sudden
our volume is equal to 2 times v1 if we
say this is double our temperature is
equal still equal to t1 we saw that a
few videos ago and we still have eight
molecules all we can say is because
the entropy of this system is higher so
now entropy is
higher and i want to make this very
clear because you never see it drawn
this way people always want to draw the
actual molecules but that confuses the
issue that when you draw actual
molecules you are showing a particular
state for example this system if we were
to look if we were to actually measure
the microstate it could be
there's a very very infinitesimally
small probability but all of the
molecules all eight molecules might be
right there
i mean it's very it's it's almost you
know you could wait for the whole
universe to come and go and it might not
happen but there is some probability it
happens so you can't assign entropy to a
particular state all you can do is
assign it to a particular
system i want to be clear about that so
even i you know i talked about a clean
and dirty room and all of that
clean versus dirty room
clean room
and dirty room and the point i was
making is the entropy of a room is not
dependent on its cleanliness or its
dirtiness in fact you could kind of view
these as each states of a room but even
more these really aren't even states of
the room because when a room is clean or
room is static at a macro level they're
static
or when when they're when they're you
know if you know if i have a a you know
my my books are aligned like let me see
you know sometimes people look at a deck
of cards and say oh if i have all my
cards stacked up like this
or if i have all my cards that are all
messy like that you know all messed up
around
that this has higher entropy
and i want to make it very clear i mean
maybe you can kind of make a knowledge
but that's not the case these are both
both of these systems are macro states
for example i mean you know these aren't
like it's not like these cards are
vibrating around any more than these
cards are it's not like these can take
on more configurations than these cards
can so when you talk about entropy
you're trying to take a macro variable
that's describing in a micro level and
the cards themselves are not the micro
level because they're not vibrating
around continuously doing due to some
kinetic energy and whatever it's the
cards molecules that are the at the
micro level and if these cards if you
have the same
you know mass of cards as you have here
and if they're at the same temperature
the molecules in these cards can take on
just as many states as the molecules in
these cards
so they're going to have the same
entropy entropy is a macro
state variable or macro state function
that describes the number of states a
system can take on so here i would view
the cards as a system and we would what
we care about is not the number of
configurations the cards themselves can
take on the cards aren't constantly
vibrating and changing from one thing to
another it's it's at the atomic level at
the molecular level that as long as we
are above absolute zero and which we
pretty much always are things are going
to be vibrating around continuously and
continuously changing its state so it's
almost impossible to measure the state
and since it's impossible to measure the
state we use something like entropy to
say well how many states can we have and
and i mean you know all of these things
entropy
whether we call it internal energy
whether you look at entropy whether we
look at pressure
volume
temperature
these are all if you can think about it
somewhere these are shortcuts around
having to actually measure
what each molecule is doing and entropy
you can kind of view it as a meta
shortcut i mean temperature tells you
average kinetic energy this tells you
all of the energy that's in it this
tells you you know how frequently the
molecules are bumping against a certain
area this tells you on average kind of
where you know the outermost molecules
are entropy is kind of a you can almost
do it as a meta-state variable it tells
you how many states how many microstates
can we take on so i just want to make
this very clear because this is often
confused and people there's a very very
very strong temptation to point to a
particular state and to say that that
has higher entropy than another that
somehow that you know this state is more
entropic than that state that's not the
case this system is more entropic than
this system
then this half box it has more volume if
they have the same temperature and the
same and and the if they have the same
temperature with more volume then its
particles can take on more possible
scenarios at any given moment in time
anyway hopefully you found that a little
bit useful i just want to make it very
very very clear because this is often
often often confused this is a macro
state variable for a system where a
system is composed of
these you know things that are bumping
around randomly every
you know millionth of a second they're
changing state so you don't even you
can't even it's very hard to even
measure one of the microstates you can't
point to a microstate and say oh this is
this has higher entropy than another
anyway see in the next video